My name is Alvin Smalls, owner of Lee Lee's
Baked Goods in Harlem: "Rugelach by a Brother."
Rugelach is a Jewish pastry.
It's made with cream cheese and butter dough.
It has raisins, walnuts, flour, and not too
much egg.
In 1962, I came to New York.
I started working in New York Hospital peeling
onions.
They had a bakery there, so I went there to
work.
Through time I went to school and I learned
how to make a lot of Jewish pastries.
Babka, hamantaschen—all this stuff I can
make.
Baking is a dying art.
Nobody is doing it like they used to.
All of the bakers like myself, there's only
a few of us left.
I love sweets, so I just changed everything
around.
I fixed it the way I like it.
At Lee Lee's, we make raspberry, apricot,
chocolate, and sometimes prune.
The first thing you do is you mix the butter,
cream cheese, vanilla, flour, and sugar.
You have to make the dough and let it sit
a while.
In the summertime, you keep it in the refrigerator,
because the butter melts easily on the table.
In wintertime, it's very stiff, so you have
to take it out of the refrigerator for at
least half-an-hour or 45 minutes.
Then you roll it out, and you have to make
about 300 pieces, 200 pieces.
Not too thin, because if it's
too thin the food can go through.
Make sure you put the flour on top, fold it,
and when you roll it, it's flakey.
For the raisin, we usually cook it, so it
can get nice and plump and so it can stay wet
We add a little honey to give it flavor.
When you put them on top, it's moist,
so it keeps the rugelach moist inside.
Moist inside, flakey on the outside.
That's it, and then you roll it up.
It's a lot of process.
Four or five other things go into it that
I can't say.
Then you'd be better than me.
Hispanic people, black people, all kinds of
people, everybody loves rugelach—everybody,
even the kids.
We had to raise the price over the years.
We started off at 50 cents, 70 cents, 80 cents,
a dollar, $1.25 last week.
We just went up Saturday to $1.50.
I didn't want to do that, but everything is
handmade—the way we put the icing on, the
powdered sugar on the danish.
I love everything about baking, period.
It's not a boring job at all.
I'm rolling dough.
I had two spinal surgeries behind it, but
it's fun.
People come up and say, "Hey, your stuff is
good," and it makes you feel good, you know?